good morning everybody and welcome to
this meeting of mid-southwark district
council cabinet
i'm councillor susie morley leader of
mid-suffolk district council and i'm
chairing this meeting today
may i remind you of some domestic
arrangements
please ensure that you maintain social
distancing from all other persons whilst
in the chamber and in the communal areas
please ensure you wear a face covering
at all times unless you're sitting down
or if you're exempt from doing so and
that you use the hand sanitizer and
wipes provided
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversations whilst
others are speaking
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off
and finally we will be using e-voting
for this meeting on the modern.gov
so please good members make sure they
are logged in and ready to use this app
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings for webcasting and
or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the press are not lawfully excluded
i'm now going to move to the agenda
please
item 1 apologies for absence
good morning and thank you tam we have
no apologies from any uh members however
the assistant director for economic
development and regenerations has folded
her apologies
and the assistant director for
environment and commercial partnership
will be here in herstad
thank you very much
item two to receive declarations of
pecuniary and non-pecuniary interest by
members are they released
councillor whitehead
thank you yes um for item number 10
i'm a counsellor director on gateway 14
which is non-pecuniary interest
okay thank you very much
item three
mca
21
46
to confirm the minutes of the meeting
held on the 7th of march 2022
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes
could i have a proposal please counselor
flatman thank you and a second
councillor hattingham thank you very
much
the governance officer will now conduct
the vote
thank you chair the vote is now in
progress
counselor
flatman are you all right four okay and
councillor fleming
that is uh nine votes full chair that's
unanimous
no it's not actually there's nine but
eight votes four and uh one abstention
okay thank you let's do that it's
carried thank you sorry
item four to receive notifications of
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme
item six matters referred by the
overview and scrutiny or the joint audit
and standards committees
there are no such matters referred to
item 7 the forthcoming decisions list
does anybody have any comments
item eight
is mca
21 47
and is the council tax energy rebate
scheme for
2022-23
and i'm going to invite the cabinet
member for finance to introduce this
report
thank you madam chairman
i'm pleased to provide a brief
introduction to report mca 2147 on the
council tax energy rebate
2022-23
expect all of us here have received
details from our energy suppliers the
very significant increases to both gas
and electric energy tariffs as well as
large increases in the standing charges
coming into effect from the first of
april
eye watering increases 50 plus
the government has announced a rebate of
150 pound for all households where the
primary residence is valued in council
tax bands a to d
mitzvah has been allocated five million
one hundred ninety nine thousand three
hundred pounds which will cover thirty
four thousand six hundred sixty two
households
and the government has asked this be
paid as soon as possible from april
approximately 75 percent of households
in banzai to d properties in mid-suffolk
pay by direct debit and after their
first council tax payment 2223
has been received in april therefore
verifying those bank details as valid
and up to date the council via the
shared revenues partnership will pay out
the 150 pound rebate
for an estimated 8432 households in
banzai today we will first need to
obtain bank details before being able to
process these rebates
the government is expecting that
payments will all be made from this main
scheme by the 30th of september this
year
in addition there will be a secondary
second discretionary scheme
here we've been allocated 161 250 pounds
or the equivalent for further 1075 lots
of 150 pounds
this is a sport though suffering
financial hardship as a result of the
rising cost of living
it can top up payments to come in bands
a to d
or for households in the higher value
bands e to h there are income related
benefits
the government expects this
discretionary scheme to be paid out by
the 30th of november this year
the council is required to create a
discretionary policy for the
administration this funding and given
the short timeline to get all this in
place
cabinet is asked to give authority to
the assistant director for culprit
resources to agree
in consultation with myself as camp
member for finance
a discretionary council tax energy
policy
it will of course be in full accordance
with the relevant government guidelines
this is set out in recommendation 3.1 of
the report
recommendation 3.2 gives authority to
the shared revenues partnership
operations manager andrew wilcock to
administer both the council tax energy
rebate and the discretionary policy
and therefore i'd like to propose both
those recommendations i would ask for
someone to second those recommendations
thank you
thank you do we have a second
lovely thank you councillor brewster
do we have any questions from members
cabinet members
any questions from any other members
cancer field
thank you a question that was um
sort of forwarded by me so
bear with me
it said um
it's actually from council rotten
indirectly the government um it says i
know i asked the question about
government fuel payments but i've now
heard that they will be paid to
landlords if tenants pay council tax
with rent to the landlord
what's
mid-suffolk going to do to avoid the
money not going to the tenant
council whitehead yeah perhaps i could
direct that to andrew wilcock who's here
but his technical question
okay thank you chair um
the government have changed the guidance
recently so we can't pay it to landlords
it has to be paid to those that where
it's their solar main residents so i
think that's where we need to look at
the discretionary scheme to support
those in accommodation like hmos
potentially if they're suffering
hardship so we won't be paying directly
to landlords
okay thank you
thank you very much
i'm now going to open this up for debate
does anybody want to start the
conversation
no
okay so the recommendations are the
cabinet gives authority to the assistant
director for corporate resources
in consultation with the cabinet member
for finance
to agree the discretionary council tax
energy policy in accordance with the
relevant government guidelines
and that cabinet gives authority to the
shared revenues partnership operations
manager to administer the scheme for the
council
for the council tax energy rebate and
the discretionary council tax energy
policy
and i now ask the government's officer
to conduct the vote thank you thank you
chair that vote is now in progress
that is nine votes for chair that's
karen
excellent thank you
item nine
mca 21-48
is the baber mid-suffolk district
council sustainable travel vision and
local cycling and walking infrastructure
plan
known to its friends as the lc whip and
i now invite cabinet member for the
environment to introduce this report
thank you
yes thank you very much and
i think i'll stand actually because i
think you've probably heard better
i'm very pleased to introduce this paper
for your endorsement today
a lot of work has gone into preparing
the draft lc whip which we have before
us by way of background the lc whip is a
national government recommended tool
and is developed in accordance with the
department for transport technical
guidance
it lays out priorities for active
travel infrastructure and investment
the county council also has its own lc
whip as have many other local
authorities or they are developing them
the oxywhip has been developed
that we see before us now through
consultation with the public
with the parishes and with communities
and
quite a large number of schemes have
come forward
the scoring process then has been um
take
completed on
the
projects and um
the scoring
has used the
active mode appraisal tool which the dft
recommends
and
this generates a cost-benefit ratio
based on potential trips versus delivery
costs and is used to prioritize the list
of schemes
and those with the higher bcrs may be
developed further to prepare them for
future funding bids
schemes with a lower bcr however still
remain relevant as they may benefit from
local funding and in particular in rural
areas the prioritization approach
that we want to use will deviate
and has deviated a little bit from the
strict dft approach
and that it's not just about numbers
it is also about need and alternatives
which for rural areas
alters the whole context a little bit
our scoring mechanism has been agreed
by a series of meetings with a
cross-party group
um the working group has after quite a
bit of discussion
um
agreed in principle for how these
schemes should be prioritized
for instance we prioritize criteria such
as proximity to schools public transport
and places of work
and we've also taken into account um
alternatives because what we found was
using the strict dft method
um urban areas tended to outscore the
rural areas and
that issue needed to be redressed and we
have tried to address that as much as
possible
i would like to stress that the list of
schemes
does remain dynamic
it will be regularly reassessed
especially with regard to new policies
strategies
or funding sources so there will always
be an opportunity for tweaks and
additions this is a living document and
i think if you turn to page 44 in the
papers you can see where that is
presented
now clearly there won't be enough money
to fund everything
and that's probably a massive
understatement so there will be
disappointments
putting in these schemes is very
expensive and schemes may not meet the
criteria for dft funding but there may
still be a high need for them within our
rural communities so these are the kind
of things that we need to grapple with
taking this forward the program is at an
early stage and i hope that our cabinet
today
will endorse the approach
and add confidence to the sustainable
travel vision
thus enabling officers to pursue
funding avenues and the delivery of
valuable new infrastructure
so thank you and thank you to officers
for all the hard work catherine you
worked immensely hard on this so thank
you very much
cancel richardson
thank you
do you have any questions from cabinet
councillor
support the principle of this
um of the paper and it's it's all
you know in its being um
i do have a really
difficult concern
because
while i've met in stone market it must
be on four or maybe even five occasions
with with officers to look at the
ipswich street
now ipswich street i did a lot of
research on it
and for safety reasons
i have always said at every meeting
that if ipswich street comes into being
then i can't put my name to it
and that's on grounds of safety
because the carriageway in ipswich
street is just four meters wide
um
it's measured between the bollards
there's about 60 mil on each width which
is taken up by curb provision
yes
the width
measurement of a transit van which was
um
going through and i realized i will be
coming to a question madam chair
um
the width measurement of a transit van
which i got measured up when i was there
in the street was 2.4 meters
to its mirrors
ipswich street as i said is just four
meters wide
there's a one-way street
and
what is in the papers there's nothing to
say the agreements we
the temporary agreements i suppose we've
made
and everyone did soon to agree that it
was unsafe
but the in the papers for ipswich street
improved signage to cyclists in the
one-way system to improve
lighting and improvement of lighting
for walkers
there is nothing about the diversion
that we were looking at
[Music]
i will vote for this
however
i do need some written
uh
work
arriving at me um
to recognize that those meetings
uh
came to some conclusions
and that is the question i have
thank you thank you councillor brewster
catherine
or cassandra
thank you councillor brewster
so our list of schemes within our elsi
whip um
currently flags up what there is public
desire for and what the public have put
forward as suggestions through our
consultation
so the detail that you see in our lists
is what we've gathered through that
community consultation
but
further investigation into what exactly
what kind of infrastructure improvements
are needed on the ground would have to
be undertaken by the highways authority
so whilst we're flagging up locations um
where there's you know been a desire for
attention
the
the finer details of the scheme
including safety considerations and the
feasibility of how it would actually be
implemented would need to be carried out
by the highways authority
so as and when they consider schemes to
bring forwards that would be worked out
in in much more detail by engineers and
designers
and so it might be that
the you know the scheme looks a little
differently to what
members of the public suggested
when it comes to implementation
thank you catherine can you just confirm
that you have got councillor brewster's
uh if you like written submissions that
he's made to you
um in the past you've got those on file
and they can be utilized as in when
necessary yes yeah and i can get back to
him writing on that
thank you
anybody else got any questions
counselor gord
thanks very much a chair um
i'm going to be slightly cheeky and and
put in a point i would have put in
debate into into a question uh as well
but uh and that that is simply to say
a big thank you to uh to cancer fleming
and the officers for for bringing this
this forward um
i'd and i think it's very much to be
welcomed and looking at my own
ward in particular which
is set so population of eye
set to grow considerably
and to expand physically as a town and
the importance of
the connectivity within the town and
walking and cycling routes is incredibly
important and that's not just us as
public uh
elected and officials saying that
actually there are
keen interests with as customer will
know within the town
itself to see more routes made available
so
this is this is very much to be welcomed
so the questions um are really
confirmation of the ability to add
schemes into
into the
program as it comes as it progresses
and the other question is really
a wider one about
this
focus that the dft has has and has
always had in its different iterations
on urban settings rather than rural
settings which means we're faced with
specifications for schemes
and the distribution of central
government money which is very much
biased towards uh
to towards
the the urban so it's really to ask
cancer fleming she sees opportunities
for taking those arguments forward
and being able to
do something about the distribution of
resources
back to the county if at all possible
thanks
councillor fleming
yes um thank you and i think um
it was very apparent when we came to
look at some of the schemes on the
ground that in order to obtain dft
funding their specifications
are
pretty uninflexible and not always
very suitable
for rural areas things like going around
trees and a little bit of lumpiness here
and there we're in the countryside
take for granted but apparently dft
doesn't um but i think
a message a broader message is
for the government when it allocates
funds
locally um and regionally that they've
got to loosen up
on
the um
constrictions and
constraints that come with those funds
and that's got to be part of what
devolution really means that's got to be
part of what we ask for as part of the
county deal and you know that would go
for the county council i know we've
talked about it at the county council
and
all local authorities
should be asking when they receive money
from central government you know
we need to make the decisions more or
less
of the deed on the detailed paths anyway
as much as possible here and not in
westminster and and i think if that
message could be taken as part of our
negotiation for the county deal be
really helpful in all kinds of ways
councillor richardson
we're still in questions yes i've got a
quick question for council fleming if
that's okay i think i know the answer to
this but i just want sort of absolute
clarity because in in your introduction
you mentioned that it's a the lc web is
a recommended toolkit um it's that
effectively does that mean it's not
something that's compulsory for us to do
that we've elected to do because we
think there's value in it am i right in
thinking that
if i could answer first and then maybe
i'll go to catherine to confirm but my
understanding is
we
we need to the way we
review and prioritize our schemes needs
to be broadly consistent with the way
other local authorities are
assessing their schemes we need to
follow the basic
matrix and if we don't then we probably
won't
be looked well upon when it comes to
certain funding sources but that doesn't
say there isn't a bit of flexibility in
it
for us especially with local schemes or
schemes that we aren't that we're
partially funding ourselves perhaps
officers could elaborate a bit on that
yeah and so to answer that question um
it isn't compulsory to have an lc whip
but it is very much recommended by
national government as a means to secure
funding so they will be looking at
authorities with lc whips in place more
favorably when it comes to active travel
funding allocations
and and
as well as sort of the national
government recommendation and districts
and boroughs throughout suffolk have
been encouraged by suffolk county
council highways to
develop their own lc whips because these
are going to be um
informing enhancing and advising the
county-wide lc whip with a much sort of
stronger evidence-based and more local
knowledge
thank you i've got a question of my own
actually
what is the process by which members of
the public will be able to carry on
asking for amendments
to the to these
sites that we put forward and in order
for it to be really meaningful
we need to keep encouraging members of
the public to actually keep putting
forward schemes for us
how will that work thank you
thank you councillor so
although our
public consultation that we ran to
develop this starting up list has now
closed and therefore gives us a snapshot
in time we do recognize that that is
indeed a snapshot in time and needs to
be reviewed and assessed regularly to
keep it up to date and relevant so our
online
consultation website will actually
remain
even though the consultation is closed
for input it remains live with
a news and project update facility so
that
anybody interested in the development of
it has you know um
up-to-date new subscriptions to how the
delivery of the lc whip goes um you know
when schemes do get implemented and
there'll be contact details on there um
to get in touch with us if they you know
feel that they need to flag up new
schemes that weren't captured in the
first consultation
and so really you know an open
conversation with us about things that
arise going forwards
and when the lc whip is published on our
website as well there will be
contact information to get in touch with
us to
raise awareness of anything that perhaps
wasn't captured already to be added to
the lists
excellent news thank you and we did have
a really good response to the
consultation didn't we with over 1800
people replying and sending in
information so that was really
successful and i think we need to
continue to promote that
thank you very much um moving into oh
sorry councillor burn
yes thank you um
i think paul you partially answered
one of the questions which i i had which
was how
what's the mechanism or machinery in in
exists to
monitor and report on the
progress of uh achieving
this uh rather impressive list that
that you have here
and
a more important question for me however
would be what's the procedure what's the
likely procedure for
assessing
the extent to which the scheme
has been successful
that i think is the more important one
the rate of success anyway has got to be
got to be taken into account have you
got anything you can
tell me about that thanks
yes thank you councillor ben so going
forwards we'll be working very closely
with suffolk county county highways
to
oversee
how we can progress with implementation
of these schemes so they'll always keep
us well informed about which schemes are
being delivered
and when they do implement a scheme it
will be their responsibility to follow
up with monitoring about you know how
that that piece of infrastructure is
used and whether it's successful in
terms of road safety mitigation
of hazards
and just you know the
the number of cycling or walking trips
that are used uh are utilizing that
piece of infrastructure so that will um
you know we will work with suffolk
county county suffolk county council
highways to ensure that that monitoring
is being fed back to us
thank you very much
so moving now into debate oh sorry
councilwoman
thank you chair i've got a number of
questions i i i wish i could make the
statements because i think it would be
more helpful if i did but anyway
am i allowed to welcome the report and
the vision document and the lists
um
i just wondered whether
uh within the vision document there
should be a reference to the electric
buses in mid-suffolk
i think they perhaps should be referred
to in the vision and as their services
are developed i think the
the walking schemes may need to to be
developed to fit into them
there's a question in there somewhere i
think
some of the schemes in the list could do
with a bit more clarification
um i think before this is submitted and
what is your question
uh it was the first question was
um
should the
uh should the vision document make
reference to
the electric buses that mid suffolk are
providing and would it be possible to
develop the walking schemes and the
electric bus services alongside each
other so that they feed into each other
a simple yes would do
i'd rather keep the questions relating
to the lc whip which is
psychology and walking
and i don't feel the need for mentioning
of buses in the cycling and walking
strategy
um
okay
i just very briefly comment on that that
one of the
scoring criteria for schemes is whether
they link to
public transport nodes
and
um so i think you know if and when
you know the buses
you know establishment we know where
those
key locations are absolutely yes that's
why this is a living document and i
think it already envisions connection to
transport nodes as being you know a high
priority in terms of assessing schemes
cass did you want to add to that
it was just to say that at the moment
the vision isn't set in stone however we
are very happy with where it is um there
is reference in there to community
transport already so um i think that's
kind of trying to capture all of that
without making it too lengthy a vision
thank you cancer willem did you have
another question um yeah i have sorry
i was going to ask if it would be
possible if the lists could be put in
the comments in the list could be put in
boxes i think when when the public see
this it will be easier for them to read
if if they are
um
and i i know the
section on updating
will planning offices be consulted
regularly and vice versa
as um
you know section 1060s and conditions
and so on uh are made and
um
and the works come to fruition
and similarly county councillors because
county councillors have a locality fund
and they may be able to put some money
in towards some of these schemes
to to help them along
thank you catherine
yeah thank you councillor
um to answer your first question about
the the formatting of the comments yet
we can put those in
boxes to make that clearer to read so
that is an amendment that i can work on
for you
um and then in terms of um how the lc
whip is utilized within the planning
authority um we absolutely want our
planning directorate and colleagues
within there to utilize the lc whip as a
tool going forwards so um following
endorsement there will be a briefing to
our planning colleagues to explain to
them you know what exactly the lc whip
is and how it was brought together and
how they can utilize it going forwards
and it's hoped that they will use this
as a sort of cross-referencing tool when
they are looking at applications to see
whether there are schemes in the near
vicinity that could benefit with some
developer funding so that is you know
an applied use of the lc whip as well
thank you very much
one more question it's simply this
um could the scheme be in east bergholt
be moved from the mid-suffolk list to
the babel list
with that i will i'll keep quiet
i'm sure that will happen
at cancer field
thank you similarly if i maybe indulge
two questions one's a bit techy and the
the other one's about uh
other things
first of all on page 30 of our papers it
talks about
the average petrol or diesel car on the
road in the uk uses the equivalent of
180 grams of co2 per kilometer
and in comparison the average bus
produces 82
just
could the officers confirm that figures
correct because i think it's important
for people's understanding of the paper
i find it a bit difficult to imagine
you know an 8 or 15 or 50 seater or
whatever bus using
less than half the co2 of a an average
car
um
and there's a point on the bottom of
that page as i'm talking about the right
hand side of the page that talks about
buses with seven passengers
is more fuel efficient than one car that
sounds much more sensible
it's quoted per mile rather than per
kilometer just to be different
but
really looking for it for officer
comment which of those two is correct if
they're both correct
i'll withdraw my question but if they're
not i think for the interest of people's
understanding it should be
it should be
the point should be
made
accurate
um so that's one question the the second
question really is about the process for
looking at these various schemes i
obviously had a quick look through those
in my area
and there seems to be a number of cases
where there they're
what looks like misunderstandings of
what actually people were
were requesting
um and it's really a matter of then how
are we going to go back to
local people and
not just saying local councillors but
local people
to get a clear understanding of what
they want
and
just exactly what's involved
so
there's um
you know i'm reluctant to use parochial
examples but there's comments there
about improving blue barn lane in great
britain
which is a
a mud footpath
to my mind little used
except when
county education are trying to get kids
to walk along it um so
that's the sort of place where you need
a clear understanding of what you're
trying to achieve and i think local
views would be valuable
so that's it two questions thank you
catherine
thank you so to answer the first
question on the accuracy i'm afraid
that's slightly too techy to answer here
um officers are confident that that is
correct however i'll go away and make
sure that we get a proper answer out to
cancer field after the meeting if that's
okay
and then on the um second question so
all of the details that have come in are
direct from the public so
it is their view so it may be what's
perceived as a little used footpath but
actually might be more or it might just
be for those people that they use it
however through commonplace we have got
all the people's contact details that
put stuff through to us so you know
there's going to be ongoing conversation
back and forth in terms of making sure
these schemes are right updating on
what's actually happening and which are
being taken forward so we can always
make sure if there are any that you
think look a bit odd or you want a bit a
bit of sense checking we can always go
back and double check that
thank you councillor mellon
thank you chair uh just a quick question
on funding
um obviously one of the most significant
pots of funding we have available for us
um is sill but as far as i understand it
still is not permitted to be used for
highways works
um so um can i ask
um can any of the projects in this list
be funded from sill and is that likely
to
change so they could be funded in the
future thank you
thank you catherine
yeah thank you councillor so um there
are
there is potential for schemes to be
funded by sill and that is something i'm
working with already with our sil
colleagues
because we've identified actually that
some of those schemes on the outskirts
of ipswich actually um fall within the
remit of the ispa traffic mitigation
strategy which is looking for seal
funding so that is one mechanism in
which still can help us deliver to some
of those schemes um i i believe it will
be location dependent going forwards but
it's um
it isn't the case that sill can't fund
any of those schemes
there is opportunities and now that
we've
gathered and consolidated and
prioritized the schemes we can really
work with our sill colleagues to
establish which schemes can benefit from
that funding
just a quick follow-up if that's okay
chet um
it's that designation of uh something
being a highway uh
um operation even when perhaps it's a
footpath which doesn't actually go
anywhere near a highway
that's the one i think that frustrates
people perhaps the most
yes there is a little bit of a
difference so highways will be anything
near or alongside a carriageway but when
we are talking about off-road footpaths
that is more within the remit of the
county council's rights-of-way team so
with our sort of both rural and urban
landscape we are going to be working
with with both of those teams
thank you
so now i'm going to move into debate
i think we've already done some of that
but uh
councillor richardson start us off
uh thank you very much chair uh just a
few points i'd like to make
if i may firstly just to reiterate what
councillor fleming has said to thank our
officers involved for the work that
they've done particularly particularly
catherine davies our sustainable travel
officer given that it has been a huge
amount of work put into producing this
document over i think the best part of a
year
and the reason i asked about um whether
or not it was compulsory is not because
it was a trick question but just simply
i can see how some other organizations
little district councils borough
councils looking at just how much work
is involved how much effort is involved
when it's not compulsory you might think
well we don't have to do it let's not
bother
that hasn't been our attitude here and i
think that's absolutely right
especially because of the opportunities
it provides to secure that additional
funding and i have to say i think that's
a one area where we are really strong as
a as a district council and it's been
securing additional investment into our
district or match funding um in other
areas so i think that's particularly
welcome
um i also think as a concept um this is
i think a really valuable piece of work
in providing that coherent strategic
approach to walking and cycling across
our our districts
and sets out you know the priorities for
the short medium and long term um in a
way that i think is really easy for
people to to comprehend and to
understand particularly when it comes to
joining up some of the existing
infrastructure that we've got
across the district and particularly
obviously important is the fact that it
takes into the views it takes into
account the views of local residents in
putting forward their preferences for
their areas and so i welcome the strong
emphasis on on the public consultation
aspect of this um especially in the
context of um being able to reiterate um
this sort of all
further iterate this document in the
future to ensure that it is a live
dynamic uh plan that keeps into into
account uh and into consideration the
views of local people particularly where
um when those schemes sort of further
develop with the input from highways and
others
um and then the last point i just want
to make obviously as you probably expect
is just to re-emphasize how important
active travel and physical exercise is
as part of the well-being strategy we
agreed uh last september i think one of
the things that we really strongly
emphasized at the time was that the
well-being strategy is not designed just
to be a stand-alone document that it's
there and that's the end of it the real
kind of emphasis from the well-being
agenda that we have as a council is
embedding that ethos into all of our
work across multiple different teams
cabinet portfolios and i think the
emphasis that this this document has
just in terms of its general concept of
what it's trying to achieve is a really
good example of delivering that in
practice so for that reason i'm hence
why i was more than happy to second um
the recommendations in the report so i
really welcome this and again thank all
those involved for bringing this forward
and look to see how it develops in the
future thank you chair
thank you anybody else
no
okay so the recommendations
are that the joint councils draft elsi
whip
and sustainable transport vision are
endorsed
and that the completion of the final
documentation is delegated to the
assistant director for econom economic
development and regeneration in
consultation with portfolio holders for
environment
i'm now going to ask the governance
officer to conduct the vote thank you
thank you chair the vote is now in
progress
counselor gold
frozen up there uh four thank you
that is nine votes for chair that's
karen
excellent well done everybody thank you
item 10 is mca 21-49
is the free freeport east
full business case
and i'm going to invite a cabinet member
for economy
to introduce the report
thank you thank you chair
um
yes i'll give you a background first the
announced in march 2021 budget free
ports are a flagship hm government
program that play an important part in
the uk's post-covert and post-brexit
economy economic recovery
there are three main government policy
objectives
the first to boost trade and investment
freeports will become national hubs for
global trade and investment
the second one
drive innovation including net zero
freeports will create hotbeds for
innovation with an aim of attracting
investment to develop and trial new
ideas and technologies
the third one
deliver jobs skills and leveling up
freeports will deliver government's
level leveling up agenda
by bringing jobs investment and high
value opportunities to some of our most
deprived communities
business will benefit from generous tax
reliefs and simply
simplified customs procedures
while local communities businesses and
the freeport sites will benefit from
investment in skills innovation and
trade as part of the wider funding
package
now to freeport east as we know it at
the moment
freeport ease covers 275 hectares of
development land across suffolk and
north essex including gateway 14
which is a tax
and could be a custom site
and port one in great plaguenam which is
a custom site
the aim of freeport east is to create a
manufacturing green energy and invite
innovation hub that capitalizes on the
unique qualities of the eastern region
which will provide space for uk
businesses and inward investors
to develop new products and processes
while creating new jobs for our
residents and supporting the growth of
our economy locally
as part of the designation process
freeport east have developed and had
approved an outline business case and
tax site designation
meaning that freeport is now live
the final stage of this process is
development of a full business case
which will be submitted to government on
the 15th of april
this full business case has now been
developed by a number of partner
organizations collaborating on working
groups which set out how freeport east
objectives will be delivered
mid-suffolk officers have been heavily
involved with the work of these groups
and continue to help shape the final
submission
whilst the leader of the council and
myself have attended the shadow board to
stay on informed on progress
the inclusion of gateway 14 as a tax
side has meant that 100 percent of the
business rates receipts for all
development on this site will be
retained locally for the next 25 years
this will be split into pots
some of which we will be able to
reinvest in gateway 14 to deliver added
value for this landmark development
most notably
bringing forward development of the
innovation and skills center
and the funding additional net zero
initiatives on site
additionally
once the full business case has been
approved by government a share of the 25
million seed funding will be made
available to support additional
investment in these projects on gateway
14.
members are asked to agree the
recommendations
contained in the report prepared by
officers
and put on record our support for this
once in a generation opportunity for our
communities and businesses
sorry
so i
recommend and propose the
recommendations
at 31
32
33 three four
and three five
and look for a second to please
thank you councillor brewster do you
have a seconder councillor whitehead
yeah thank you man chairman
as i said at the start of the meeting
i've been a counsellor director on
gateway 14 actually since its inception
and this development with the freeport
east i believe is a really exciting um
opportunity uh it really is the icing on
the cake for the for our site
in stowe market because the tax and
customs advantages for businesses
and the ability the councils to retain
business rates uh should is a real bonus
so i'm very happy to secondly
recommendations
thank you councillor whitehead
do we have any questions from
cabinet
from anybody else
councillor miller
yeah thank you chair i have four
questions hope that's okay
um the first two probably i can
put together
um
can we confirm that established local
firms would not be able to
open an office in gateway 14
and secondly will companies operating
outside the freeport be competitively
disadvantaged compared to those
benefiting from the tax advantages
inside
michelle
with us this morning and i think she is
better prepared for a lot of these
questions than probably i am having only
sort of got into it a little bit
soon later
thank you chair and the first question i
can
relatively easily confirm that
established companies within the local
area if they choose to locate on gateway
14
if they are growing their business
and adding additional staff or
additional investment in their business
will still be eligible for the benefits
that come with the the gateway 14 tax
site designation
what government are looking to do is to
ensure that the designation and the
associated financial benefits that it
brings
do not
encourage businesses to to relocate
simply in order to access those
financial benefits so what they're
looking for us to work
with businesses who may be interested in
relocation is to ensure that there is
added growth um and that it is not just
simply displacement of jobs from one
site to another
we are working very closely with the
team at gateway 14 and janek in order to
be able to manage any inquiries that
come through from local businesses
and any that have been received so far
are very clear that they they fit the
criteria for significant growth
um so that i wouldn't have any any major
concerns but what it would also do
in a secondary um
benefit locally is
encourage churn in the market so
potentially by a business moving on to
gateway 14 it frees up additional
development site within the within the
wider geography that will be available
for other businesses to move into as
well
in terms of the potential disadvantage
for businesses that are not on the
gateway 14 site and therefore not able
to access financial benefits
there is a
as part of the
business rate retention
program that councillor brewster
referred to there is something called a
pot c which is an investment fund that's
available for
investment to support the wider
geographic area that includes
the majority of suffolk and north essex
once that program is set up it will be
able to support investment trade skills
and development opportunities for
businesses and geographies outside of
the main tax sites so whilst the
businesses themselves wouldn't have
wouldn't necessarily get the same
financial incentives as those that are
on a tax site it doesn't mean that there
won't be any opportunities available for
businesses and for
for
investment in the wider support
thank you girls
thanks for that clarification um
and two further questions then um
councilor bruce to mention
about the
freeport being a green energy hub and
there's a lot about hydrogen in in the
prospectus
uh and particularly for the the ha the
harrage component of the freeport what
measures will be used at gateway 14 to
ensure it is
carbon neutral and then my last question
is um previously we heard a lot about
gateway 14 including a food enterprise
zone but this seems to have gone quiet
is it still included thank you
thank you michelle
thank you um
i will potentially leave a number of our
councillors who are also on the gateway
14 board to jump in if there are any any
areas that they feel like i haven't
covered
in terms of the gateway 14 site we're
looking at
a number of energy and sustainability
initiatives to be included including the
development of
an on-site energy network idea now i
think the technical term is
we're
ensuring that all of the buildings are
solar ready so
they have the ability for solar panels
to be to be added to the roofs we're
looking at battery technology we're
looking at
some of the buildings particularly the
innovation and skills center to be net
zero and an exemplar building there are
significant
commitments already made by gateway 14
limited as part of the planning
permission for some of those um
initiatives and what we're looking to do
through the freeport designation is to
extend and enhance the the net zero
offer on site through some of the seed
capital and the retained business rates
to make sure that we're providing some
added value for the development
and in terms of the food enterprise zone
designation that's a designation made by
defra in
2018 i think it may have been
um
that designation hasn't disappeared and
neither has the enterprise zone
designation that was conferred in 2016
what government have said is that
ultimately businesses will get the
choice as to which of the three
designations that they choose to
um to work under
um what
that means in practice is that for
certainly for the next five years
financial incentives for businesses will
only be available under the freeport
designation
and therefore we would expect that most
businesses would choose that route
rather than the food enterprise zone or
the enterprising designation
however
we are still
very keen to encourage food
manufacturing businesses to locate on
gateway 14
as part of that legacy from the food
enterprise and designation
and so create still working to create a
food cluster
thank you
now i'm going to open it up for debate
does anybody wish to start us off
i'm sorry i'm
i didn't quite hear are we starting
debate debate yes sorry yeah
um i can say something
if that's thank you
um well i just want to say that i really
welcome
um
this um
this whole project to mid suffolk and to
suffolk um i think it's a really um
great achievement for this region to
have freeport east and
especially for stone market to be part
of it
there's great synergy here with the
development of energy in the region um
and
emergence of this region is a nationally
important center for generating low
carbon energy and related technologies
so i think um i think we're in the brink
of of something here that's really very
exciting
but um
as this develops in the future i would
like to see
some more
green quote-unquote
um
aspects
that aren't considered viable now
possibly brought in and we think we need
to keep our eye on them and i'd like to
see for instance all of the available
roof space
used for generating solar energy
i don't understand why
solar energy can be viable on green
agricultural fields but not on
brown fields and on roof space there's
something really fundamentally wrong
with the way
this whole program is being
funded and supported
where we've ended up with a situation
like this so i would really urge change
there and of course
i would like to see a rail connection i
hope one day that will prove viable
apparently it isn't now
but with the way fuel prices and changes
in
priorities may evolve in the future i
think we need to keep that option open
anyway i'm
very pleased to be able to support this
paper thank you
thank you
so the recommendations
3.1 that the submission of freeport east
full business case be endorsed
that the assistant director economy and
regeneration and the section 1 151
officer be given delegated authority in
consultation with the leader of the
council and the cabinet members for
finance and economy to finalize the
detail on the freeport east full
business case on behalf of mid-suffolk
district council
but the proposed incorporation model for
freeport east
i.e a company limited by guarantee be
approved and the cabinet make a
recommendation to full council on
nomination from mid-suffolk district
council director
that the retained business rates policy
be approved in principle
that forward funding from the growth and
efficiency fund of 80 000 pounds per
year for two years in advance of the
retained business rates be approved
and i'll now ask the governance officer
to conduct the vote thank you
thank you chair that vote is now in
progress
councillor gold
sorry still frozen uh four thank you
that is nine votes for chair that's
carried
thank you thank you very much everybody
um so the date and time of the next
meeting is scheduled for monday the 9th
of may at 10 30.
meetings closed at 11 32. thank you
everybody for attending